[Music]
hello everybody my name is Julian
Polanco I am the national master from
the state of Missouri and today I'll be
going over the Rogozin so the regardin
is a sister opening to the nimzo-indian
which starts out after d4 I was sick c4
e6 and here if Y were to play Knight c3
then most most people who play the
rigo's and would play Bishop before here
Trinity well immediately going into the
NEB zone but some people avoid the nihms
oh what the move Knight f3 and well you
have to have a new defense against this
move now some people like to play the
Queen's Indian and some people like to
play the BOGO but right now we're
talking about the Ragosa which starts
with d5 93 and this move Bishop to b4
our starting position so just like the
nihms oh the bishop is pinning the
knight to the king it is controlling the
e4 square putting taking more control
over the e4 square and the central light
squares and this is a very solid opening
where black has no real weaknesses now
we can go over the I'll go over the
opening all the main moves and sidelines
and then we'll look at some games and
believe it or not in our class tonight
we have some masters and grandmasters at
least half of that statement last year
which half we do not know anyway so here
I'll ask the audience so it's White's
play what would you like to play with
white is there anything that you notice
about the opening your thoughts yeah so
if black were to move again then
obviously he'd be threatening to win
impalas 93 actually he'd be winning an
exchange but it's it's not black to
player no it's
wait to fire a queen bee three yeah so
Queen B 3 is a line it's one of the
least common lines because you're
putting pressure on the bishop and maybe
some you're attacking d5 but the real
problem here is you're violating like a
principle right you should have moved
your queen out in the opening right
right is C 5 is the response it takes
his best knight c6 Bishop g5 and Queen
a5 now there have been lots of like
high-level games here black has no
problems equalizing because I have a lot
of pressure in the center and binding my
darts on the diagonal with 94 and the
tension is about to be released on d4
and
oh in my material back so Bishop f6
there's only one good move for black
here so would anybody like to take a
guess
so if you take the bishop what would be
the potential problem with this month
yes but there's something more important
so if you take the bishop immediately
there's an intermediate move you can
play instead then white will take on d5
and now your pawns are not only ice not
only doubled but isolated instead the
best move is D takes c4 which is forced
because now okay you're attacking the
Queen
so white is no time to save the bishop
on our six points e4 g f6 and it's true
you have doubled pawns now and maybe
your king is a little bit exposed but at
the same time your pawn your pawn
structure these pawns are doubled but
they're together so they're stronger and
you have the G file to work with and
probably you're regaining your home back
on c5 play might continue rook c1 queen
c5 Queen h4 Keane e7 g3 Knight a bishop
c3 be c3 b6 with roughly balanced
position so Queen b3 isn't a bad try but
it does not offer the most chances Queen
a4 is one of the main lines yes we'll
look at some games with Queen i-4 so the
point of Queen a4 is in every double
queen pawn opening there's a pawn break
that white wants to achieve and that is
C sorry both sides want to achieve so Y
wants to achieve c4 and black wants to
achieve c5 so by playing Queen a4 you
are attacking the king and the bishop
and you're forcing black to play knight
c6 defending both but when you play
knight c6 you can no longer move your C
pawn so this is a slight concession from
black for black now black tries to solve
the problem with his light square bishop
by other means
here there are many lines the main move
here is e 3 castles Bishop d2 is d sorry
yeah DC Bishop c4
and here Bishop d6 also possible as a
six we'll look at a game with a six
later Bishop d6 castles and e5 with
again rough rough equality because all
of my pieces are supporting supporting
this break even though the you you would
normally want to play c5 I've changed my
plan to play u5 all of my pieces kind of
make sense
they'll have nice diagonals and scores
to work with play might continue d5 97
before Bishop c4 should be to c6 d c9 c
Bishop e3 Bishop f 394 equality so Queen
a4 is definitely definitely a try for an
advantage now some people like to play
the same position with Queen a4 but if
you might notice in in our line that we
just discussed Queen a 496 you were
playing III and Bishop d2 and the bishop
isn't very good on d2 right like it's
kind of passive it's not really
contributing to the position so some
people like to play Bishop g5 h6 is the
main move Bishop f6 Queen f6 Queen a
four-night knight c6 and III and they
have the same position except they've
got rid of their problem once you want
this was seen between I believe Aronian
and so we'll also take a look at that
game in a bit Aronian and so Sinquefield
the sing field kept actually this last
single go Aronian want a very nice game
with white yeah so the two main main
moves here are Bishop g5 and C takes d5
now after Bishop g5 there's a problem
for white that after h6 you cannot play
Bishop h4 because normally white can
regain the pollen c4 and in most like
Queens gambit accepted lines like by
playing B 3 but since black has pressure
on this diagonal b3 is really hard to
achieve
so like III b5 like there would be I'm
just going to show like a Queens gambit
accepted position d4 d5 yeah yeah the
Vienna the Vienna is very similar to the
row goes on I'll show that in a second
too so here like white if he wants to
regain this point okay a four is best
here obviously but there's a way you can
regain the pawn with b3 takes and Bishop
b5 let's check and then you take the
pawn back on b3 this is also fine in in
our variation here after Bishop Bishop
g5 h six Bishop h4 DC for b3 is very
hard to achieve with the bishop being on
before obviously the night his hand just
hanging right
the Vienna is the same thing here except
instead of playing Bishop before a black
takes on c4 now there's a there's a
slight problem with the for me with the
Vienna I I actually don't like this line
with you for I might talk about that in
it like later I I really think these
these lines
I mean if blacks not losing by force
it's it's very close
so yeah returning returning to the row
goes on you know the pawns are Klein's
with you for are very dangerous in the
Vienna so Bishop g5 age six white cannot
maintain the pin with Bishop h4 because
DC for is sorry
yeah DC for is just good for white I
mean block sorry III b5 a4 c6 in the
Queens gambit accepted there would be
this tactic where you would take on b5
and then play Queen f3 because the Ricca
straps but you can't do that because
your Knights on f3 tough luck
all right so that position just good for
black so some people like to play C
takes d5 C takes D 5 and then Bishop c5
and this is actually the main line so
there's no more DC for like I'm white
immediately solves that problem
and this position might be slightly
better for white now this is basically
the main tabia of the Vienna and many
things have been tried here so c5 has
been tried castles been tried
basically what they ended up figuring
out was h6 is the best move Bishop h4
Bishop f6 isn't really anything anymore
because after Queen f6 especially these
Queen f4 lines they're just not
threatening this isn't really important
but I had a game that went knight c6 III
castles I believe it should be five four
shipped you for ship C 6 C six here
takes takes takes takes takes it takes
and my opponent was an IM believe it or
not and I I just won like this like
blacks plus three already so yeah these
these lines aren't threatening at all
but after Bishop h4 black has some
problems along this diagonal and usually
I'm sorry the old way to handle these
positions was to play 97 the slightly
more modern way is to pledge you 5 or C
5 and G 5 and the new way to play is
castles the new way is best but we can
talk about each separate position
position so 9b d7 III c5 should be 3 C
for Bishop f5 so black is trying to
advance his majority on the Queen side
because he has pawn majority on that
side as pawns are pointed pointed in
that direction so that's the site he
wants to play on
white is trying to take advantage of
maybe the weaknesses the black is
created the d5 pawn is arguably weak and
so as so as the f5 square because of the
'some of h6
so Knight b6 trying to trade off the bad
bishop for the good
so Bishop c2 now you might think why am
i playing like ship f5 but the knight is
actually worse on b6 than it is on D 7
so for ship C to 2792 castles castles
rook e8 and why should be slightly
better here just because at some point
he's going to prepare F 3 and E 4 and
then he'll have two pawns in the center
and have very nice central control and
black has a lot of problems with
finishing his development and finding
good scores for his pieces all of
White's pieces make sense like the
knight on c3 in d2 they protect e4 so
like my plan of plain f3 you for makes a
lot of sense and also my bishop want to
see two controls this diagonal my bishop
on h4 is is pending the night and okay I
mean it's not like this is all bad for
black like black has a nice nice control
over the light scores like c4 and d5
complex gives them that that extra space
but this position should be slightly
better for white so people didn't like
playing like this with black so they
came up with sorry with c5 III and then
C for stopping the bishop from reaching
d3 entirely so at some point maybe my
bishop will go to f5 Bishop b2 and g5
53 and the point is I've released my
knight from this pin and now it goes to
a floor to put more pressure on the c3
square or nightmare
Brooke c1 queen i-595 knight c6 castles
basically right now well white is
targeting f7 so like Bishop h5 is it
might be a threat in the future and I
mean with black has black has made some
serious weaknesses but on the other hand
c3 is incredibly weak and black is very
active Black has put all of his pieces
on this one square and is doing a very
good job of targeting it both sides have
interesting play here knight c6 is best
castles with with a wedge this one
instead of 96 with with what with Knight
c3 so first of all let's recognize that
Bishop c3 is not possible because after
Knight c3 there's Queen d2 and there's
this pin right but yeah so the problem
with playing like this Knight c3 bc3
Bishop c3 is I can just play keen f1 and
I'm playing h4 anyway and you voices
sometime and since this bishops on c3
I live I'll have Tempe on on this later
so white gets huge compensation but here
96 is best with I'd say still a slightly
better position for for white now sorry
which position right because I'll have
the H file that's true so I should I
should mention here that after age six
Bishop H 4 C 5 e 3 C 4 in this line that
we just talked about white doesn't
really care about 93 because after h g3
I get pressure along the H file so it
doesn't matter if I'm on Castle yeah
pointed out by GM canwest alright yeah
so the best way to play is after Bishop
h4 just to Castle and here for a very
long time people thought this was just
like a mistake to play Bishop f5 but
this is the best month now normally
again in like double queen pawn openings
whenever this happens this will always
be true when you move your bishop off of
c1 it's not on c1 it sounds simple but
that means that b2 isn't defended so
there's lots of openings like the Slav
where if you just move your Bishop from
ca to f5 he'll just lose the b7 point
and it's true that's what happens here
so the bishop moves to a5 so b7 is not
defended so the best move for white is
to play Queen b3 putting pressure on b7
Bishop c3 and here BC three Queen c3
we'll look at in a moment BC 3 is still
best 97 so black isn't playing isn't
playing b6 because this weakens all of
the light squares in a waste time black
is instead trying to play four breaks in
the center and immediate development so
97 is best now okay if your opponent
gives you a pawn you have to check if if
you can take it right so Queen b7 this
is a variation but actually black is
more than fine here
after c5 Queen i6 c4
so c4 cuts off the communication between
the
the bishop the Queen can't return home
easily queen a3 couldn't be six and this
is already this is already equal
basically every single legal move for
black is fine
rook a b8 rook FB 8 a 5 basically any
move you can think of is fine because
black has enough pressure for 4 is
jettisoned upon so immediate so if
you're wondering like what black would
do he just go play like play my
continued Rick be a poor should be to a
queen bee to and it's very hard for
white to develop even because castles
would lose the knight on D 2 so this is
this position is already very very nice
for black if I could get this in a game
I would be very happy a better way to
take the point is to instead of playing
Queen b7 immediately is to play Bishop
e2 C 5 and now Queen B 7 but here still
Queen I five castles rook b8 Queen a six
takes takes c4 so the bishop is kind of
trapped but a four because that's the
only is the only move right like
otherwise I'm just playing with b6 and
taking the bishop on e6 so here a for
work b3 should be 5 g 5 94 and I
immediately regain all of my material
with once again a roughly equal position
see ya any questions so far about the
opening no
alright should expect no less from our
master and Grand Master alright see ya
that's that's basically everything
everything so let's move on to the games
so the first game that we're gonna look
at is a is between buy zone and Fisher
so they they got here
yeah they got here through some funny
move order yeah I was still a place back
in nineteen sixty so Bishop before white
plays the main move in this game CD five
CD 5 Bishop g5 so h6 now we know that
after Bishop h4 the best move here is
castles which is even given as a
variation they used to think can see -
but what does Queen c2 c5 it directly
transposes to a line of the nihms oh
yeah fly is everywhere see if I was put
in this game I mean a Fischer play
something it can't be so bad it's not
III ninety six ninety six is a little
weird even for like the time everybody
was playing maybe five
but ninety six Bishop e2 g5 here anyway
ninety four so Fisher's going for the
same kind of thing he's trying to put
pressure on the c3 Knight and just
claimed that his activity outweighs the
pawn weaknesses that he's created
Brooksie one Queen f5 castles bishops
III be c3 Knight c3 yeah for sure was
notorious for taking pawns he shouldn't
take Queenie 192 Queen e2 but sometimes
he's right so who knows so we need to
take a timeout here what do you guys
think of this position do you have any
recommendations it's like who do you
prefer any thoughts
so obviously white is down a pawn so
raise your hand if you like being down
upon yeah yeah when it's pretty serious
compensation right because of the dark
squared bishop opposite color bishops
which means there's more like there's a
more likely chance for an attack right
because you can dominate on one color
complex so this helps white obviously
now what else so you obviously black
scheme is weaker than whites right here
white white has already completed
development but in exchange for all of
this black has a pawn so let's see who
is right
you believe in Fisher yep
c4 obviously c4 needs to be played
because if you if you just allow me to
take on c5 with anything then I I win
I have compensation and it's I mean I
have compensation and material or
something the material and compensation
b6 isn't very good because it weakens
more squares I mean after a four gets
played I'll be rough well maybe there's
Fischer p6 I don't anyway c4 c4
this is the obvious break that white is
playing for whenever you have this
structure right this is the thing I mean
when the kings in the center you want to
open the position and this is the the
thing you want to target on d5 so e4
Bishop e6 Bishop c7
all right
so so quintics obviously so b6 doesn't
doesn't help and now at the point is II
d5 so now I've opened the position with
white and maybe you misplaced your
equipment but still G 492 what would
what would you play here with black well
okay if you Castle kingside
like now then I take on e6 yeah I'm
taking this guy yeah I'd be scared
maybe Fisher's not scared but I would be
scared okay yeah so 94 queenie for and
now what black to play
that's correct yeah there's a nice trick
here with Queen f4 and the point is if
white takes on f4 now you have now you
have 92 th one and night of four and
black is just clearly better
so instead white us to avoid the Queen
trade because he's on material so rook
c4 or sorry yes - he has to collect his
material back with her super Queenie for
avoiding the Queen trade here would
allow 92 so if you play Queen back
somewhere like here then I take on e3
and play 92 or Queen e1 doesn't help
it's all bad
so rook c4 Queenie for take 92 th 157 so
can anybody tell me the problem with
taking on d5 the check this check this
check all right very good
couldn't fold the GM all right Bishop d7
let's play now the point is okay keen f8
stepping out of any potential problems
on the e-file can anybody tell me what
the problem with Ricky 2 is that's
correct it should be 5 and you have some
problems I mean you already had problems
but it also in shows so here Knight of 6
was played should be 5 work here bishop
basics maintaining a an eye on the u2
night 97 King moves back to e7 because
if you go to g7 GeForce hanging 95 and
here the point is rook e8 takes King d6
and can anybody tell me the move after
it be 793 that's correct
take rook e1 and now how would you
finish the game so whenever you have a
position like this where there's two G
pawns in the Kings on and you have
control of the back rank the King can
never move forward right so you move the
rook to the c1 and that's made on h1
it's unstoppable and white resigned so
yeah Fischer won a very nice game
against as long to it okay let's move on
all right training so we will reach our
starting position here Bishop before
sorry what yeah actually you know the
first and only world championship match
that he played in the first game he
played a Ragosa he lost that game you
know Bishop you know Bishop H - yeah I
mean okay the games yeah yeah
the games like a hundred moves long
which is why nobody remembers the
opening but it was also yeah he when
when you played people he respected he
played there we go
anyway uh Bishop before CD Edie so this
is once again the main line of main
lines age six Bishop h4 + c5 so these
are older games which is why c5 is being
played actually like we're gonna look at
more modern games later or castle yeah
castles castle is better than c5 just
because it's it's c5 is really committal
and it also wastes the tempo so if you
can develop right you should so but c5
also isn't bad because you get immediate
pressure with Queen f5 later III 96 so
Fischer continues in the same style Rick
c1 c4 but in this game
we'll see if white handles it any better
castles 92 sure if it goes back to e7
now can anybody tell me the pawn break
that white wants to achieve
Claudia already knows he's like yeah be
three well this kind of be three might
help you but the one that you like
really want to achieve is our three new
for right b3 b3 is definitely another
another pawn break that it when it's
good it's really good in fact be through
his plane so on g5 Bashir g3 Bishop e3
Rick c2 now white intentionally traps
his own rook after night before
I mean Fischer is good at taking stuff
it takes takes the question is is it
good night b5 and Bishop goes back 97 so
this works the rook on a8 and the bishop
on e6 and I mentioned that black had
really nice lights we're control now
LightSquared control in the position
that's not sure anymore
black has zero light scar control once
so Bishop d2 is played actually best is
all right so I'll show what Fischer
played but can anybody improve on on his
game what's what's the winning move here
for white
I mean sorry Fisher isn't white but his
opponent all of sudden queen g6 can
shoot
so if queen g6
so if queen g6 can H a takes here
all right so here
yeah the e3 signing yeah you can't play
if yes actually this is this is all
correct the only thing he needs to know
is not to take back on our six probably
he calculated all this and was like oppa
ship f6 doesn't win but Bishop c4 is
just completely winning for white yeah I
mean black is in total paralysis
yeah this position is just winning for
Roy wait you Queen f8 you just moved
back King g8 Bishop f6 finally Bishop e6
and Rick b1 and White has a lot of
activity and we'll continue with the
winning attack yeah not only that but he
also has enough material to compensate
for his piece anyway and the game
continued true Grand Master fashion its
Bishop c4 no risk
Queeny 8 yeah so if you move your bishop
away no that's close to the same check
here check here it's even like better
now because I can take here stuff here
which is a good move it's hard to stop
mate and takes if you go Quinn g8 then
this is embarrassing if you go Queen e7
then it's the same Bishop f6 and clinch
7 so yeah
you can't just move your bishop away
anymore you have to play queenie 8 then
Queen d2 and black has an exchange but
White has two bishops so black gets rid
of the two bishops so queenie for
centralizing the queen attacking the
weakness on e6 Rick see it but should be
three Queen d7 d1 advancing the pawn
majority on the King side five cream
queen moved to f5 okay so g4 is played
because if Queen g4 then Queen f6 and
now he white just rolls with the points
f5 56 ship e6
and he took all these guys now this is
um important because why doesn't
actually winning it's just much easier
to play white he was winning earlier and
I will allow you to play the best move
here now if you don't play this move you
resign so could make a big difference
black to play and not lose weight what
you want to take this guy that's right
but isn't but in like Rick endings the
two passengers are more important really
slow
yeah but my professors are on the fifth
and fourth and yours are here so I have
an extra yeah I mean yeah I assume this
is just losing because I take work
before so I go here here it this way
this way
you take a go here so I also have like
Keens safety tonight yeah I don't know
it should be it should be when I get you
this in time
no but it's actually much simpler than
that there's only one thing you need to
worry about and that's these these pawns
moving so I'll show what happened in the
game really fast what happened was Rick
g3 Rick g8 kini 7 g5 and why just one
because I'm making a whole bunch of
Queens
so Bishop d5 was played to protect you -
ok this position is completely winning
four way so let's go back so how do we
prevent that from happening how do we
prevent g4 to g5
that's correct rook up for his best
because now rook g8 now that now the
Jeep on can't move because I fives
you're saying so this position is
actually just equal so g5 work on five
Rick g6 you
it's much easier to play wait here I'll
grant you but yeah I'm sorry
Ricky for know ah computer stop before
probably and if I take this one go then
I'm happy
ish never happy
alright anyway the game finished with
white making multiple Queens so Bishop
d5 protecting g26 rook e8 resigns
because every pawn is going to be a
queen so a white a white one a brilliant
game in their chosen dark the next game
is between let's Nika and Shakira
ramadhir off so we again have funny move
orders so yeah the Virgo zone is only
allowed one the Knights on f3 so
starting with nine of three mixes more
likely so Queen a4 obviously trying to
misplace the knight on c6 III oh yeah
so today I had a very long conversation
the friend of mine who and we we looked
at 95 extensively for like no reason
just just what we did it's not so
important but the two best moves right
here would be a five and Rick B 8 a 5 is
funny I I kind of like it because it
sets up a fun a really nice trap 96
takes takes Bishop d7 and I you think
you think you're safe with Queen B 7 but
94 and 96 threatening Knight c3 Queens
just trapped
and you like brief mention III castles
Bishop d2 a6 so yeah the main move yeah
yeah so after after Knight e5 here here
attack in the pinned piece the best move
the best moves are a5 and rook b8 both
are about equal I mean white doesn't
have to take the pollen c6 the point of
rugby it is simple my bishop needs to be
protected right now it's being protected
by the night if you eliminate the knight
then it'll be protected by the rook
so yeah 95 is in a very good move but
some high-level games have I have been
played their e3 castles and Bishop
Bishop d2 we again earlier mentioned
that DC for Bishop Bishop c4 Bishop d6
is equality because of you 5 so this
position should be about equal maybe
okay I don't know if a6 is like in the
older move or something but I feel like
it's more it's it's not trying to
equalize but put up like a fight so like
black also wants to play it doesn't want
to just make a draw but anyway a 6 Queen
c2 rook e8 a3
well this definitely justifies what
black is done because in our line
earlier we were playing Bishop DS D c4
and Bishop d6 unprovoked but here we
gained a full tempo and castles and
rikiei
the rook wants to be on e8 anyway as
we're trying to prepare the break 65 so
a through Bishop d6
h3 h6 so once again in the event that
white takes on d5 black would really
like to play Bishop g4 that is
impossible
after h3 I take your Bishop and also
potentially
how do I get rid of pain all right so
when white achieves III II for if the
pawn isn't on h6 then white might want
to play Bishop g5 so that's why these
moves are interpolated c d e d Bishop d3
Bishop d7 so it looks like blacks pieces
are all very passive but I first want to
burn my pieces to the center and then
think about doing something before oh
yeah sorry
so this position as I said the knight on
c6 is poorly placed so I'm trying to
reroute it to a better circuit so Knight
a 795 it's the plan Knight a for b6 to
stop Knight c5 Knight c3 Knight b5
potentially if if my bishop moves away
the knight would have a nice score on d6
controlling you for also if I trade off
these Knights that would that would be
fine here 94 anyway because a4 isn't a
problem they'll just weaken the before
one so yeah 96 castles can anybody tell
me why Bishop a6 is not playable well
play a it is play a little bit why it's
not good knight c6 and if b5
yes that's correct night PA
and you are sorry actually this is
stronger take six a night before a night
be it's also good because the point is
basically I just take the mission so
yeah anyway 97 castles 96 b5 take take
take take here and black has gotten to
bishops and exchanged for two nights and
two bishops are usually an advantage so
this position definitely shouldn't be a
cause for concern for black
anyway 95f 696 Queen d7 yeah so here it
looks very nice for for white like white
has a knight on c6 it's supported by an
outpost but my question to you is what
does the knight do on c6 like it's
attacking empty squares it's attacking
d8 be a day 7 in e7 but there's it has
little to no contribution on the
position like here I am very confused as
to what the knight is actually doing
here it's more like a paper tiger so f3
Queen f7 I think like is clearly better
here already but ok I'm slightly biased
towards the bishop pair f4 rook a 1 I
said yeah rook a one work a 157 trying
to get rid of I mean well not really but
maybe giving the square u e6 to the
Queen
4 can't you 1 g6 can g7 and finally
black it's the a file so a bit of moving
around fine so this move traps the rook
now this is check bishop c1 here Queenie
four okay so this transformation it has
been very successful for black because
all of all of whites pawns are in dark
squares so black kept his dark squared
Bishop because he wants to take all
those bombs so now that it's on c1 it
can start taking everything now black
played Ricka Ricka seven attack in c7
and I will ask you the audience what you
would like to play here with black
nice all right Queen f4 is correct the
the point is after GF Sree f you have
Bishop c4 and rook e1 always check so
black is up to pawns and easily winning
also bishop and rook is better than
night and rook you internet people can
hate me all you want all right
also if white does nothing like okay
actually it's hard to play a nothing
move but like if you play King g1 or
anywhere on the back rank my queen
protects my rook so I just moved my
bishop but when your queen if I play
Queen f2 then I take on e3 it's my
bishop and then take on for and take
everything else instead the game ended
like this
Queen f4 key niche one queen f2 also a
nice move if you saw a queen now for you
can see Queen f2 because it's the same
tactic if queen up to then I have Bishop
e3 followed by immediate mate actually
so check is re not check Queen takes
Queen check here
takes and I mean I don't I don't know
how you stop - if g3
I mean g4 is probably forced that's not
good not good
especially because I probably just take
all your pieces yeah it's not it's not
good and if you do it here like like
this right takes here I mean soon
yeah Rick check looks pretty good
probably just Bishop back followed by g2
yeah it should be winning
pretty easily I mean blacks already up
material so bare minimum at this point
like g4 you could play Bishop g3 give me
well anyway the game continued rook c7
kh6 Queen d1 Queen e2 so yeah now it's
actually a lot simpler so after I
actually was it the same way no it
wasn't so in this position after Queen D
1 if you take my queen then then I have
so you see it right alright anybody
who's not Claudio its forced to me like
to play
teenage to
Oh f4 but you're done a queen yeah it's
it's forced made so you can calculate
all the way to the end I believe in you
all right everybody at home already
knows because of their engines but
Bishop f4 g3 so the bishop III first
move is correct okay I think everybody
saw this if Bishop f4 now just g3 and
white as when you plot twist
all right so teenage to Claudio reveal
yes that's correct
yes very good
believe it or not the master saw it all
right so after Queen dee one Queenie -
when Ji Won was played queen III queen
f1 queen of 423 where k1 resigns because
it's hard to stop mate or mate or
anything else so it's hard to it's hard
to find a movin well both players were
rated above 2600 well one was 2700 so
yeah moment you are it's not a bad play
this is a game between who Cara Nakamura
and Shakira Elmendorf we will reach our
starting position with Bishop b4 and
once again Queen air for shock 96 III
castles we've seen all of this before DC
Bishop ca6
Bishop back to d6 can anybody tell me
why b5 for doesn't work good just making
sure you weren't asleep 56 5 take sticks
now you might be thinking well like the
Queen and the rook are lined up
shouldn't there be a tactic here or
something
the problem with having the pollen III
is there are no impressive bishop
squares I mean I'm not really scared of
Bishop e1 or Bishop c1 they're not the
things that keep me up at night but okay
anyway Bishop e2 27 getting I mean
potentially the bishop won't be terrible
so we have to get off of the D file 95 I
was a little confused by night g5 the
best I can come up with this that he
wanted to play 94 and try to take the
bishop on d6 but I don't think 95 should
be repeated
Bishop up five you 4:57 getting the
tempo and black brings all of his pieces
into the center all right so there's
this moment that I will ask you it is
black to play what would you do
no the real problem here is yeah okay 92
is the answer which claudia was
calculating okay well we'll come back to
that in a second so the problem with
like Queenie is sex like just in general
like you're not really exposing my king
with this kind of sacrifice
and I mean okay so there's a rule right
that every attacker should know you
divide the board into quadrants right
and if you have plus two material and
that on that side of the board usually
you're winning there right so let's say
my queen were on and I have a good
example of that or I don't know if you
saw were you there for my tactics
lecture no I had a game between myself
and some GM and I moved a piece away
from from the Kings side and then he
played me I mean not like matin won but
like in something that uh something nice
and I this is like if you look at like
old Kaspari of interviews he'll talk
about this role a lot if you look at
tall games like the basis for his attack
is usually justified by this rule so and
the fact is after HG you have zero
pieces on that side of the board so you
can't be like mating me like logically
just I mean with no calculation anyway
h3 so night of to the obvious move the
point is you get and you've destroyed
the the castle King you've taken two of
the very important points and you have
one and two pieces contribute to the
position no you're not just winning it
because I have one
winning by late plus one but came back
to g1 bishop g3 so it's very important
the King steps back to g1 can anybody
tell me why I mean okay it doesn't
matter what you do when you're lost but
what ya 94 is the problem because then
Bishop c5 but actually first I think
stronger is Bishop c5 like you reverse
the order the King can't go back and
then if Bishop e3 you have Knight g4
which is a very strong for like so you
have to you have to move back
immediately just because when the Kings
on do you wanna can go to the H file but
if it's checked on f2 it can't go back
so I know
Bishop g3 Bishop F on let's played
Bishop be one rookie one yeah push it
back to G for ff3 Queen to d6 attack in
d2 and more importantly g3 rookie to 23
and 94 so the Queen's coming in to h2
not h1 h2 and I have all of my pieces
are playing and it's not at all clear
what white pieces are doing so here 91
work e6 burning more pieces into the
attack see he's he can't win yet right
because white has enough defenders so
you have to bring more you have to bring
reinforced reinforcements in in order to
finish the game
so 93 rook to c6 displacing the Queen
couldn't be one Queen h2 queen of 4 and
white resign resigned because of rookie
to next
oh I mean obviously if you could he
would so anyway let us move on to the
next game I'll briefly talk about the
games now kind of exhausted a lot of my
time so anyway so this variation I
mentioned earlier where white was
getting destroyed and well basically the
two games we showed but it's not
actually true like wait why it's okay
but after Queen I 496 III we have to put
our Bishop on day two so white says okay
I want to play Bishop c5 take and play
Queen I fourth now my Bishop isn't
terrible I've traded doll for your
knight
anyway this is a a game between a ronin
and so you can find find this game in
many places just note the Bishop d7 is
like the main move here and so play
Bishop c3 which is slightly inaccurate
but still should be perfectly fine for
black yeah yeah then Ben has a video on
this yeah I would highly recommend
checking that out but yeah well just
just a quick note in the opening I don't
think he mentions this at all but I
mentioned this earlier too I mean not in
this lecture but in earlier class here
after 94 this is the critical like point
of the game Wesley so played Queen f5
and all engines say this is like fine
for black after like perfect like 20
only moves right and I I don't I don't
know if I believe that like it's it's
very unclear if that's if that's true
but best hear an improvement will be
Queen h4 point being that I'm attacking
the knight
this way you defend your night or
playoff for its cut off communication
between the queen of the night other
moves like Knight g3 are also fine 93 96
and then you bring your queen back to e7
because the queen is exposed on the
Kings side so you need to bring it it's
it's your most important piece you don't
want it just like hanging around where
it can be a tax or be a potential
weakness so you bring it back and then
you put your knight back on a5 because
that's his best square targeting c4 and
once you place see five and here keen f8
black should be perfectly fine also good
is is rook e8 or kita is also fine
another another thing I hear is f4
Knight to c6 again you bring your queen
back and then you put your knight back
on a5 and this is just a look yes
instead in the game black out a very bad
position because after Queen a5 Bishop
d3 so white is posing black potential
problems with this Queen and I mean when
the Queen and Bishop are lined up maybe
there will be some tactical resource
like for example I can never move my
rook c8 or e8 because of 96 and Bishop
c6 which was played in the game is
actually the best move f3 takes takes
Queen g5 all of this is best according
to the engine but here I think a slight
improvement is f6 over 85 I don't know
why e5 seems perfectly logical to me
rook D will look after you sorry rook DF
1 CD 4 is inaccurate the best move here
is rook f8 and the way that black would
potentially be holding is after Queen f2
takes takes Queen e7 and this position
should be very slightly better for way
in the game he got totally totally
demolished after after he traded on d4
and a lot of the pawn to reach d5
and the night's a little bit cut out H
for ticks and Queenie five and now White
has a mass of pawns in the center and
bishops are better than Knights and that
file the fil is important and blacks
Queen is better than whites Queen
everything's going in whites favorite
here the game didn't last too much
longer so Queen e7 Queen g3 Queen c5
rook f6 I mean the G pawns pin so the
rook can go there
h5 rook h6 attacking the H pawn queen c3
h5 g 6 e 5 and black resigned because
notice how many pieces are attacking the
King side 1 2 3 4 how many pieces are
defending 1 2 so white is wedding
hopefully you enjoyed my analysis on the
rigo's and this was Julian Polanco thank
you very much
[Music]